magic spoon tastes exactly like your
favorite childhood breakfast cereals but
it has no sugar lots of protein it's
keto and low carb friendly it's
delicious without the guilt get five
dollars off when you click my link below
and use the promo code pacman i want to
start today with some rare good news
when it comes to just the process of
voting in the united states you know
we're
waiting to see
whether democrats will be able to push
forward the voting rights bill that joe
biden has been talking about now
intensely for the last week or so
but absent that there are so many
different ways in which republicans are
not even fighting the so-called battle
of ideas which they claim to prioritize
and instead
fighting to win elections by subterfuge
and deception
and systems control rather than winning
people's hearts and minds so
gerrymandering is one of these ways
that republicans have sought to and have
benefited from
uh manipulating the system reducing
ballot boxes in minority neighborhoods
limiting voting hours trying to stop
mail-in ballots mandating specific ids
including ids that uh require that while
themselves may be free
required documents which if you don't
have them are not free to obtain
um putting in place partisan actors to
oversee
the count or whatever the case may be
it's relentless it's exhausting and the
first element of that that i mentioned
is gerrymandering and we have you know
you've got to look at this big battle
or this big war and the different
battles within it
within the battle around gerrymandering
we have a little bit of good news in one
of those sub battles and that news is
that the ohio supreme court has decided
to throw into the trash
the republican gerrymandered maps and
has given 10 days 10 days to fix it the
ap reporting the ohio supreme court
declared republican-drawn legislative
maps invalid wednesday yesterday
agreeing with voting rights advocates
that the lines were unconstitutionally
gerrymandered
in a 4-3 ruling the court sent the maps
back to the ohio redistricting
commission to take another crack at
complying with provisions of a 2015
state constitutional amendment which
requires there be an attempt at avoiding
partisan favoritism
these maps in ohio are so gerrymandered
that there isn't even evidence that they
tried to avoid partisan favoritism
justices gave the panel 10 days and
retain jurisdiction to review the
handiwork
the dispute comes amid the process of
redrawing legislative and congressional
district maps that states must undertake
once a decade to reflect changes from
the u.s census there's a bunch of
interesting elements here one of which
is
republican governor mike dewine a member
of the commission and whose son was
among wednesday's dissenting justices
pledged in a statement to work with my
fellow redistricting commission members
on revised maps
think about that
republican mike dewine
is a member of the redistricting
commission
and his son is one of the justices on
the supreme court who said the maps are
fine that my dad was involved in in in
drawing and writing it i mean it's it's
you know
there are so many ways in which this is
just absolutely insane
and you've got to fight these battles
one by one and this is the difficulty
when they have so many ways you know
they talk about winning the battle of
ideas and the problem is they've lost
the battle of ideas when you look at the
country and you say
do most people believe that the
government has a basic duty to provide
some health care to everybody regardless
of ability to pay very popular statement
not reflected in our elected officials
not reflected in uh the actions of our
elected officials when you say well
what's the position on abortion uh
nationally well
legal in most cases is the opinion of
more people than ever before in the
united states is that reflected in our
elected officials no
they're not winning people over in terms
of hearts and minds and policy
they're winning with gerrymandering
making voting difficult for the people
that they think would be to their
advantage to make voting difficult for
all the other things that i mentioned
and then when you even take the war
and then you look at one battle
gerrymandering and you look at that
battle in one state ohio you find oh one
of the guys who was involved in drawing
these lines which are crazy partisan was
mike dewine
and one of the justices on the ohio
supreme court deciding as to whether
those lines are okay or not
is the son of mike dewine it it's just
it's truly stunning that this is what's
going on in this country but it is and
so we've got to fight these battles one
by one the battle
it's not even that it's been won yet in
ohio there's the opportunity to win it
by getting more fair maps drawn they
have 10 days to do it now 9 since the
decision was yesterday we'll follow it
and we'll let you know what happens i'm
going to play a video clip for you today
which is really a great example
of um reporters
doing what they're supposed to do which
is when you ask a question and it's not
answered
you ask it again and if you're not able
to ask it again your colleague asks it
again this you you've got to see this
one of the things that was done in
arizona after the 2020 election
was that
an alternative
uh uh slate of electors signed a
document saying that they were the
electors from arizona now you might
remember joe biden won arizona and so
arizona sent democratic electors to
washington dc to say
arizona casts our electoral votes in
favor of joe biden nothing controversial
there
um we now have uncovered
fake state documents falsely declaring
that donald trump won the 2020 election
on tuesday rachel maddow shared five
fake certificates of ascertainment sent
to the national archives in an inc
ill-conceived plot to make it seem as if
trump had won
one of the republican lawmakers who
signed that fake document is state
representative jake hoffman
jake hoffman was confronted by a number
of reporters and asked
why did you sign a fake declaration it's
bogus joe biden won
why would you sign that jake hoffman
seems to realize he may be in legal hot
water here he tries to avoid answering
the questions he's asked them again and
then look at how he simply
implodes
and says he doesn't know how he even
ended up in a position to sign it this
is unbelievable take a look at this
when bram wants to ask a real question
happy to have a conversation with him
okay thank you sir
okay so the question was how did you end
up being in the position of being an
elector given you're a republican joe
biden won okay so
here we go let's see what he
says i'm asking you that question wonder
what authority did you find yourself as
an elected so in unprecedented times
unprecedented action is occurred there
is no case law there's no precedent that
exists
as to whether or not a an election that
is currently being litigated in the
courts
has due standing now understand that
everything he just said is bs the
arizona election results were by
definition not being litigated in the
courts when they tried to send an
alternate slate of republican electors
in january there had been legal
challenges between the election and the
certification of the election which
happened in november and december
respectively at the time that it was
certified it's no longer being litigated
in court
just because you submit something and
keep submitting submitting submitting
stuff to a court
saying you believe it should be disputed
doesn't mean it's being litigated the
the everything he's saying is untrue now
when he says that there's no precedent
there's no reason to believe
that you would be able to send an
alternate slate of electors just for the
hell of it because you keep filing
disputes and disputes in court the
election had been
yes disputed between november and
december certified and at that point
it's no longer in dispute legally
speaking so what he's saying is
completely bogus but watch how much
crazier it gets which is why we felt it
appropriate to provide congress and the
vice president with
dueling opinions did you have direction
from anybody in doing this
was it you eleven yourself to doing this
or did someone give you advice on so
this is a great question did the the 11
of you who said we are the electors
rather than the actual electors did you
guys do this yourself or did someone
tell you to do it the matter in which
you can do it
so i'm simply i was one of the electors
right i'm not in charge of the electors
so you would how did you hear about you
you wouldn't drew here you would need to
ask the party
how did you hear about the plan
you would need to ask the party this is
so unbelievable
he's just being asked
okay
you're one of eleven
who told you hey
we're gonna do this we're gonna do this
document how did how did the plan come
together
you're the person who received the call
you showed up right how did you know to
show up that day so as i said you can go
ahead and ask the party chair the
logistics of it
how you got a phone call or something
you're welcome to talk to them about it
do you not know how you arrived at a
place thank you i i appreciate your time
i know how you got a call have a great
one the other questions
this is just this is really really well
done uh understand what he's saying it's
like it's sort of like if i say um hey
uh
when i used to be on a dodgeball team
right intramural dodgeball team or
whatever
um you're here playing right and you
have teammates yes okay how did you know
to come here today
you get you got to ask somebody else no
but i mean like is there a schedule how
did you because you want to play
dodgeball and you think playing
dodgeball is good but how did you know
to be here at six today like was is the
part of a league or oh no no no
it doesn't make any sense and this guy
realizes that he's in legal hot water
reporters should be doing this in the
press briefing room when one answer gets
blown off
you have to the next person has just got
to ask the same question same question
same question now is it too much to
expect prosecution here here because
what they did is very soon what they did
here is extraordinarily serious
understand that they sent a document
representing that they are the electors
when they are not the electors joe biden
won arizona um this
there are a number of different
possible crimes here and i'm not even
going to list them because it's all
still very early and lawyers are sort of
in the speculative phase but can we
expect prosecution here i don't know the
answer to that i fear that the answer is
no but really good job done by those
reporters make sure you're following me
on twitter and let me know what you make
of it
it is a brand new year maybe you have
goals around getting in better shape
maybe cutting back on sugar
that's why you should check out our long
time sponsor magic spoon magic spoon
tastes exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar 14
grams of protein and only four net carbs
so it's perfect if you're doing low carb
or keto or if like me you just try to
limit your sugar intake you can build
your own variety pack with flavors like
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle maple
blueberry that's my favorite magic spoon
lets you enjoy a sweet delicious snack
without the guilt you can stick to your
goals and still treat yourself and if
you don't love magic spoon as much as i
do they'll give you all of your money
back no questions asked magic spoon is
giving my audience five dollars off when
you go to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman our
program depends on the support of our
viewers and listeners you can make a
contribution and get tons of extras
while doing it by getting a membership
at jointpakman.com we do an extra show
every day for our members called the
bonus show you can sign up at
joinpakman.com yes we are still banned
from facebook monetization five or six
different people are lobbying on our
behalf but we are as of now uh four days
into a 90-day monetization ban so you
can sign up at joinpakman.com
with the coupon code f facebook quite a
quite quite a coupon code okay one of
the things that we have been kind of
discussing
we i mean me with many in the audience
is how we should react to the deaths
of the unvaccinated or more specifically
the anti-vaccine individuals
anti-vaccine individuals who prominently
say we're against the coveted vaccine
and then they die of covet
i get emails all the time
from people saying david you really
shouldn't gloat about anti-vaxxers dying
and i agree i don't gloat about
anti-vaxxers dying i've said time and
again i feel terribly about people who
have been misled into thinking the
vaccine is a bad thing and then they get
covered and then they die and their
family members grieve and it's sad i
don't gloat about it
but this is super interesting there's a
column in the los angeles times
by michael hilsick
which says
we should be mocking anti-vaxxer deaths
and it is a fascinating read we will
link to it and i encourage you to look
at it
michael writes
among all the ways that covet affects
our lives the pandemic confronts us with
a profound moral dilemma how should we
react to the deaths of the unvaccinated
on the one hand a hallmark of civilized
thought is the sense that every life is
precious
on the other those who have deliberately
flouted that's not flaunted remember
that's a word flouted sober medical
advice by refusing a vaccine
known to reduce the risk of serious
disease from the virus including the
risk to others and end up in the
hospital or the grave
can be viewed as receiving their just
desserts
that's even more true of those who not
only refuse the vaccine for themselves
but publicly advocated that others do so
it has become common online and in
social media for vaccine refusers and
anti-vaccine advocates to become the
target of ridicule after they come down
with covid and especially if they die
from it witness the subreddit herman
cain award
the site is named for the former
republican candidate for president who
became one of the first political
notables to succumb to the disease after
publicly defying social distancing
measure measures like another site sorry
anti-vaxxer the subreddit hosts snippets
and photographs of anti-vaccine
advocates often taken at their deathbeds
the issue of how to think about the
deaths of unvaccinated has been thrown
into high relief locally by the case of
kelly ernby remember we covered that
that's the orange county republican who
was against the mandates and died of
covet unvaccinated
ernby's death promptly came to symbolize
the rift in the social fabric caused by
the ravages of covet and then it goes on
to say that some of what is happening
with her is bigotry and hate
um
michael hiltic has a different take he
says to begin with let's stipulate not
all unvaccinated people are alike some
are unvaccinated for legit medical
reasons children for whom the coveted
vaccines haven't been ruled safe for
someone with a real medical reason some
may have faced obstacles in getting to a
vaccination site others may have been
may have refused the vaccine because
they've been deceived by fox news or
whatever else the deaths are truly
lamentable finally there are those who
have voiced public opposition to the
vaccines not all of whom are
unvaccinated themselves ernby was in
that category she asserted opposition
not to vaccines but to mandates
and hiltsick goes on to say
it should be clear
that opposing vaccine mandates as a as a
substitute for opposing vaccination
itself is a fundamentally incoherent
position it's little more than the
garden variety small government
republican ideology
hiltik points out the significantly
lower vaccination rate
of republicans
and says
mandates do work
requirements that people provide
evidence of vaccination
have been associated with heightened
vaccine rates
as for whether vaccination mandates are
a slippery slope to more government
control which many of these people
maintain
government mandates for vaccines have
been with us for decades and for other
kinds
wearing seat belts having airbags in
cars banning smoking in public places
and that these mandates exist because
the diseases threaten not only the
infected people but also the community
and hiltic goes on to say
ultimately
that it is so pernicious that we have
these people around
advocating against vaccines or against
vaccine mandates that in fact we should
be ridiculing them that in fact we
should be mocking them and that in the
long run even though it feels like a
ghoulish thing to do
the same way that vaccine mandates work
mocking those who are anti-vaxx uh uh
outspokenly anti-vaxx or anti-mandate
and then die
actually is effective at getting people
vaccinated that it might feel wrong as i
have said and many of you have said but
that it is actually a necessary thing to
do because of the public health
consequences check out michael hiltzik's
opinion piece and i would love to hear
from you about this uh let me know what
you think
speaking of vaccines uh there is
something very interesting going on
which is that donald trump the former
president
although he was softly dismissive
of vaccination when it comes to any kind
of requirement and continue to play up
freedom we all need our freedom we all
need our freedom
has actually become
a very forceful advocate for the safety
and efficacy of covet vaccines
and we have an incredible clip from
yesterday donald trump did another
interview with oan so you've got fox
news which is crazy right wing
you've got news max which is even
crazier and then you've got oan which is
even crazier than newsmax
and donald trump was sort of softly
confronted by the reporter about there's
all these people concerned
there's all these concerns about the
vaccine
and donald trump very forcefully said
it's ridiculous and by the way listen to
when trump says there are uh officials
who are not even telling the truth that
they've been vaccinated i believe he is
signaling ron desantis here and i'm
going to get back to that let's check
out this clip because a lot of viewers
wrote in i put a kind of all call out to
our viewers on the program if you had
questions for the president what would
it be top two election integrity we'll
get to in a second but the other one was
the vaccine right you recently stayed in
an interview with candace owens and when
you were on the road with bill o'reilly
doing uh the book tour and the speaking
engagement that you've had the vaccine
two shots and you've had the booster
right
and you recommend it for folks
we have seen with the vares report
there's tens of thousands of side
effects now remember the vayor's reports
are unverified this is important anyone
can submit something to vares anybody
the the their we can't glean anything
from vayers side effects in this vaccine
any vaccine history and more deaths dr
robert malone nine patents for the mrna
technology being used in the vaccines
remember robert malone's claims have
already been debunked he came on my
program weeks ago and said unless you're
over 65 and have a co-morbidity i
recommend it other than that i don't
recommend taking it he even
is upset he took it himself he's having
heart issues
looking back we know that warp speed was
great you did amazing with getting rid
of it and and the talking out of both
sides of the mouth the rapidity with
which you got these vaccines done is
amazing
we just don't want them because they're
not good vaccines getting them is great
using them nuts it's completely i mean
it is a pretzel it is a pretzel tape to
get something out there
but after now so many months of the
vaccine being administered and these
side effects and americans questions of
it
do you reconsider your push for it or
what's your view now on the vaccine in
general well i've taken it i've had the
booster
many politicians i watched a couple of
politicians be interviewed
and one of the questions was did you get
the booster because they had the vaccine
and they oh they're answering it like in
other words the answer is yes but they
don't want to say it he's very clearly
referring to ron desantis there and this
is already a signal about if desantis
wants to be the nominee in 24 and trump
wants to be the nominee in 24 it's going
to get very ugly very quickly which i
love
because they're gutless you got to say
it whether you had it or not say it
but the fact is that i think the vaccine
has saved
tens of millions of people throughout
the world
i have had absolutely no side effects
i've had it like other people have had
it nothing special
so donald trump here
is
he
other than the fact that he takes credit
for the vaccines for which he deserves
no credit the the u.s pre-purchased
doses that's all they did
trump deserves no credit for the vaccine
these vaccines were going to be
developed in this amount of time no
matter who was president uh you could
have had uh you know barney rubble as
president these vaccines would have been
developed um
trump is absolutely right about what
he's saying and it is crazy that these
networks now are having to sort of play
put themselves in these pretzels
hilariously this guy on oan still
equates trump to jesus to see to just
look at the level of sycophancy now look
he's not perfect
no one is
he sins i sin we all sin
but as you know
who did our savior jesus christ hang out
with back in the day
who did he use to spread his message or
do his will right guess what they
weren't famous
they weren't politicians they weren't
rulers or tyrants
they were lepers
they were prostitutes they were the
blind and the deformed
the people that society had cast away
yeah they were in a word
deplorables right so there we go they
still love trump and see him as a
god-like figure
when trump is the voice of reason
you know you're on an insane network and
i without any hesitation trump's lying
about his role in the vaccines but what
trump is saying
about the vaccines themselves is
absolutely right okay real quick i don't
want to spend a ton of time on this but
i want to just show you that the tucker
carlson fox news program has become a
complete and totally open platform
for conspiracy theories at this point in
time that's all it is yesterday i showed
you how tucker loves this ray epps the
fbi did the trump riots conspiracy
theory and he used ted cruz to push it
he then had on glenn beck who has
coveted right now and allowed glenn beck
to push the uh washington state covid
internment camp conspiracy theory if you
haven't heard about it i'll tell you
about it in a moment
the great reset is not a conspiracy
theory it is something that the davos
people have put together along with the
world economic forum and it is running
rampant through every western capital
and every western company country it is
i just i just read this tomorrow morning
at 9 30
uh the washington state covet detainment
emergency
they are going to have a state board of
health discussing from 9 30 to 3 30
tomorrow allowing health local health uh
officers to use law enforcement to force
an emergency order in involuntarily
detaining a person or group of persons
families to be isolated in a quarantine
facility following the refusal to
voluntarily comply with request medical
examinations testing treatment by the
way if you're not watching tucker's
doing the confused face the entire time
here sling and vaccination
this is an internment camp washington
state has done it before they haven't
obviously learned their lesson from
world war ii
this again is all about total and
complete control now everything glenn
beck is saying is a lie this has been
widely debunked let me tell you what's
going on no writes krem
washington won't forcibly quarantine
those who have coveted or are
unvaccinated
the state board of health has received
thousands of emails about an agenda item
that will be discussed this week
claims are going around that washington
politicians are trying to create laws
that would allow them to force
unvaccinated people into quarantine
the state board of health received
thousands of emails we set out to verify
claims the question does this proposal
allow health officials to use law
enforcement to force an emergency order
to involuntarily detain a person or
group in a facility if they refuse to
comply with requests for medical
treatment testing treatment counseling
or vaccination the answer no
the state isn't trying to quarantine
forcibly those who have coveted or are
unvaccinated
just to be really clear
our board meeting on wednesday
is there are no conversations about
isolation in quarantine camps there are
no rules existing or in the making to
create isolation and quarantine camps
there are no rules and there is no
process in place to create a rule to
involuntary core involuntarily
quarantine or isolate covet 19 positive
people
regardless of vaccination there are no
laws and no plans to do it
period it's just bogus it's this is
nothing there
and tucker carlson's fox news program
which is i think at this point the most
widely listened to right wing program
i i mean maybe joe rogan is considered a
right-wing program now and has a bigger
audience but it is one of the biggest
right-wing programs
every day there's a new conspiracy
theory if you watch tucker and you
accept the stuff on there the feds did
911.
uh i'm sorry
the feds did the trump riots not 911.
maybe they say the feds did 911 too i
don't know the the feds did the trump
riots is what i mean
um and they're gonna in turn there's
gonna be an internment camp for people
with covid in washington every day it's
a new conspiracy theory
extraordinarily dangerous stuff and if
you're just listening today we'll have
these clips up on our instagram which
you can find at david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
today we're going to be speaking with
sheila alechi who is a reporter with
icij and also coordinates the
organization's partners in asia and
western europe thanks so much for
talking to us today
thank you
so
my audience has certainly heard of the
pandora papers we've reported
i don't know about extensively but we've
reported about the pandora papers for
people who maybe aren't familiar with
what these documents are how do you
generally summarize what the documents
are
well i would say that pandora papers is
an investigation based on a leak of
about 12 million documents um
confidential financial records coming
from 14 different
financial service providers from around
the world from the most secrecy uh
secretive jurisdictions including
seychelles cyprus uh bvi and so forth
and
what these documents tell us
is how the offshore financial system
works but not just that also how the the
global economy in a way works because
the system that thrives on secrecy and
anonymity is basically a big part of the
global economy right now and
sorry some of the biggest headlines
related to
individual prominent individuals
politicians elected officials
functionaries of other kinds well-known
people um
i don't know if secretly is the right
word but certainly behind the scenes
using a lot of these other other
mechanisms and instruments for their own
personal finances is that a fair
assessment
i think so what we found was that more
than 300 politicians including more than
30 current and former
country leaders used shell companies and
offshore trusts to hide wealth
from their own citizens as well so
public
elected officials
such as the president of kenya the king
of jordan
the then prime minister czech republic
and other prominent politicians um use
this kind of structures to um to
hide wealth or buy real estate around
the world and
obviously we have to be careful here we
don't want to say that all of this is
illegal
much of this actually is a legal and
legitimate but um the problem here is
actually that
it allows um
people to avoid scrutiny
and so it can be used
by
you know husbands who don't want their
divorces to know about their assets
as well as criminals who don't want
authorities to know about their assets
how does the icij um obtain these
documents to the extent that you can
talk to us about the process
yes we don't comment on our sources um
we obtain these documents and
what we did initially
was um
fact-checking uh most of them and trying
to figure out whether they were actually
whether they were accurate and where
they were
you know fake fake documents and um the
way we do this is a process that we have
learned to do over time because this is
not the first offshore financial project
that we do
we obviously check the leaked documents
against public records
we always
involve journalists from many different
countries who have the expertise and the
sources who allow us also to verify the
information whether it's true or not and
as you know we don't publish we don't
publish the whole data set because there
are confidential information and also um
you know information that is may not be
true so um we try to um you know go
publish publish only stories that we are
able to verify and um and um also ask
comment for yeah i wanted that was going
to be my next question about asking for
comment in many types of stories
uh when someone is written about you ask
that person for a comment there's a
deadline they have the opportunity to
say something or to say no comment or to
not even respond at all
here
the the story is really the documents
and if the documents are accurate
the concept of a comment is a little bit
different right because it's basically
do you what exactly are we asking for
when we ask for comment about a document
well we want to know the context because
sometimes you don't have the story in
one document you may know that one
person
set up a company and that's it you may
know what it is for sometimes you don't
even know what the purpose of this
company is so obviously we want to know
we also want to know the purpose
for example if it was for tax reasons or
not
um and then obviously you know we also
wanna um just give the opportunity to
anybody um to
to say to have their say and um seij
alone we are about 15 reporters and
editors on staff and we sent more than
400 comment requests just for this
investigation excluding all the requests
that our partners um have sent so every
name that is
on our story uh we will will be
you know fact-checked and
they will have the opportunity to
comment now out of the 400 how many
chose to comment
no i don't know the exact percentage but
i must say that what i've noticed
is that over time people especially
politicians have developed a very good
strategy and most of them did not
respond or did not respond adequately or
they chose not to respond to our
questions and wait for after publication
to go on their social media and facebook
and you know give their own opinion
there directly to their um followers
you mentioned that a lot of what is
revealed is not against the law
but it can be used in ways to
circumvent reporting requirements or
there's a lot of different ways in which
these mechanisms can be used how much of
of the investigation is
talking to lawyers about
is there anything illegal here and
highlighting the illegal
a lot
a lot of because we are journalists we
are not experts obviously we've been
doing this for many years so there are
some basic um
you know concepts and knowledge that we
have but at the same time you also want
to be sure that um you know
you are up to date with the most recent
legislation or regulation etc and also
here we talk about uh hundreds of
countries so each country has its
specific regulation and after panama
papers which is an investigation we did
in 2016
some laws changed so you also want to be
sure that what you're reporting now is
um obviously up to date
so
yes we we love experts
and
they are they they always help us uh
understand um
the context uh
sometimes when we have teams reporting
teams from many different countries we
also have experts from many different
countries who kind of um tell us what's
going on
so for this i want to give a little
context for my next question in the
united states certainly and i think this
happens in other countries too whenever
there's a leak of information
if you like the content of the leak you
focus on the content and you ignore how
the documents were obtained if you don't
like the content of the leak you ignore
the content and you say how dare they
get these private documents you focus
only on how it was obtained when we're
talking about banking records i mean
there certainly are
privacy laws and different countries
have different rules the same as with
medical records with with banking
information
how does the icij
think about
that at the end of the day these
documents are
presumably documents that are are
believed to be private documents and how
what is the sort of ethical approach to
that so first of all whenever we publish
a name or a story we always ask whether
it's in the public interest so i'm not
going to publish my neighbors uh you
know banking records nobody cares about
that but i do care about a politician i
do care also about a powerful business
person who may have a political ties or
any impact on a community um
obviously i do care about criminals so
um that's some ethical um discussion
that we you know we have always have
before uh publishing anything um and
then again you go and ask for comments
so you don't do it behind the the back
you know like you always um try to
confront the the people that you're
writing about um so it's not a surprise
um and
when i say we go to co for comment we
have um
you know we we asked about at least five
weeks before publication so that we
can always ask at least three times
um calling i have sent for example last
time i sent an email
not an email a registered mail to
myanmar you know because
there was only a physical address that i
could use and you try whatever you can
are there um are is this the type of
investigation where for your team
there are physical security concerns for
the reporters that are doing the
investigating
so lucky
icij's team most of it is based in the
u.s or in europe
but of course we work with journalists
from around the world and
you know from russia uh hong kong for
example arab countries and we have a lot
of and also in latin america many latin
american countries have freedom issues
so um
more than the ics staff obviously we're
always concerned for our partners and we
work with them every day we're always in
touch so if there is an issue for them
we try to to help them for example one
thing that we do is if a partner cannot
publish a story in their own country
there may be a partner in a neighboring
country that can publish that story for
them so that the person or the reporters
in trouble can report on something that
has already been reported without
exposing themselves so we try to so
that's why collaboration is great
because it also help protect each other
um and especially people in you know
more vulnerable vulnerable uh situations
whenever there are these these big leaks
and revelations
um there's the question of okay so what
is the ideal
consequence or outcome
with you know you look at the edward
snowden nsa leaks and there are a lot of
people who said well the the outcome
should be now that people have been made
aware of these techniques
those should be changed they should be
made illegal or well you know there's
kind of like a clear path what's the
goal here is it sort of international
tax and finance policy reform or what
would be the outcome that would be an
ideal outcome
well surely transparency is something
that we will hope
to have more around the world you know
and after panama papers for example the
some countries introduced laws to um for
example reports record the beneficial
ownership um and so forth and every time
obviously that we do a project like this
new loopholes emerge for example this
time something interesting had to do
with the us and what we learned was that
while smaller jurisdictions for example
like bahamas were trying to improve
their own system uh huge you know
economies like the us that were actually
becoming um the go-to place for people
to hide money um and so this time we
really hope that if the u.s that
actually step up and
improve uh their own regulations
when it comes to people like elton john
uh jackie chan you know shakira named in
the papers
talk to me about the public interest
there and to be clear i'm not saying
there is no public interest it seems
different than an elected official that
might influence policy however so i'm
curious about the public interest when
it comes to entertainers you know um
i understand that there is a difference
between a politician an elected official
and a pop star but at the same time
these people have a lot of influence
even if it's just uh um
you know on people a lot of impact on on
every everybody um and so they kind of
like they they chose a public life in a
way and so obviously um
the their their finances um if obviously
if we find something that is worth
reporting um then that can be um you
know um put on scrutiny um at the same
time we always go and ask for comment
and so for example um there were a few
of these um celebrities that
came back saying that they had done
nothing wrong and um which we also
reported like models etc um
but you know this is a system that
really
that we want people to understand why it
is significant at the same time whether
if while it is legitimate
in some cases
you know you still have tax revenues
that are lost
so we want the public to be informed and
whether it's a politician or a celebrity
that contributes to the system i think
it's still worth talking about it
well it's it's an incredible
investigation and i encourage uh people
in in my audience to uh go to the icij
website and there's so so much
documentation there we've been speaking
with sheila alechi who is a reporter
with the icij uh i really appreciate
your time today thanks so much for
talking to us
thank you
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show i want to look at a clip from uh i
believe it's yesterday's joe rogan
program joe rogan interviewed a friend
of our show josh zepps very good guy
i've been on his show doesn't mean josh
and i agree on everything
uh but i've always
known him to be a a good guy
josh appeared with joe rogan and the
topic came up of myocarditis risk for
young men from the covet vaccines
important topic
joe rogan was presented with the
evidence that the risk of myocarditis
from having covid is significantly
higher than the risk of myocarditis from
the vaccine in both cases most everybody
recovers no problem but the risk of
myocarditis is higher if you get covid
than if you get the vaccine
in real time you will see
really disappointing goal post moving
and techniques from joe rogan that are
really typical
sadly of the people that email me and
are clearly set in their ways and don't
want to have their minds changed so
let's take a look at the conversation
this is this is interesting it's also
really sad pointing myocarditis more
common after covid19 infection than
vaccination but is this what uh-oh so
first it now here's a study
the study already says
myocarditis is more common from covid
than from the vaccine so that already
goes against what joe rogan has been
told and i'll show you part of where he
got it
children uh
yeah we're talking about young people so
um rogan now says well i'm really i'm
talking about it within young people
only boy is aged under 30 after this is
what it says here so as you can see the
study as as uh
jamie points out
includes up to age 30
and that includes younger and that
includes up to all the way up to 30.
with children is the issue well no rogan
says i'm only concerned about children
here we're talking about 15 year olds
well we're talking about young children
12 to 17. 12 to 72 more like develop
myocarditis with three months of
catching covet at a rate of 450 cases
per million infection this compares to
67 cases of myocarditis per milliliter
josh
points out correctly
look at the 12 to 17 age group is that
young enough joe even among 12 to 17
your risk of getting myocarditis from
covid
is about eight times higher than from
the vaccine
time following their second dose of
fiber pfizer yeah so you're about eight
times likely to get myocarditis from
getting covered than from getting the
vaccines that's interesting that is not
what i've read before but also it's like
when even when we're reading these
things it's like what are we getting
this from who is this well this is a
peer-reviewed study and there's numerous
peer-reviewed studies that have been
done on this so so
notice the goal post shifting it's okay
now there is a claim that the risk is
actually higher of myocarditis from
covert than from vaccines but can we
really trust what we're reading well
yeah actually we can
report but even
from the vares reports when they report
this stuff it's like the amount of
people that report the um like it's the
under reporting so now there's a new
thing which is rogan says
even if you consider vayers which is not
even verified
rogan says it stuff is being
under-reported so
this study
is based on
under-reporting to veyers when we know
the real issue with vares is actually
over-reporting completely unconfirmed
reporting notice the goal post shifting
that takes place depending upon who you
ask and like what it is it's either one
percent under
okay
so um this is uh unfortunately
this is what happens a lot of times when
you when you have these types of
conversations with people now i had this
conversation not long ago i have a
family member who works in pediatrics
and i said before i got my third dose
you know i'm kind of freaked out because
now when you sign up for your third like
i'm the most pro-vaccine person when i
signed up for my third dose it had me
understand it said do you understand
that there is a risk of myocarditis and
it just freaked me out and the person i
was talking to said yeah but david
remember
the risk to people your age
from covid of myocarditis is higher than
from the vaccine and here's studies that
we've been looking at and i looked at it
and i said oh you're absolutely right
right that that makes sense um and a lot
of this goes back to that uh peter
mccullough appearance with joe rogan
where mccullough was talking about
vaccine-induced myocarditis and did not
mention by the way the risk of
covet-induced myocarditis is
dramatically higher than from the
vaccine so i wish that joe rogan had
received this information differently
really nice job by josh zepps and as
i've said before i welcome any
opportunity to go back on and talk to
rogan about exactly this issue
when uh comedian and actor bob saget
died
and there was not immediately a cause of
death announced
i told you guys
uh there are people who are going to say
he died from the vaccine from the covet
vaccine there's no evidence of that
there's no reason to think that that's
what happened but people are going to
say that and of course i was right and
i'm not patting myself on the back it
was obvious that people were going to
say that because any time there's an
unexplained death now football player
dies must have been the coveted vaccine
bob saget dies must have been the covet
vaccine a prominent right-winger candace
owens is now pushing exactly that
conspiracy now
there is no evidence for it
but she doesn't care
let's take a look at what she had to say
so
am i a conspiracy theorist or am i
nostradamus
the answer is neither i'm just not on
big pharma's payroll now remember a lot
of the people claiming that their
position on vaccines is because they are
not on big pharma's payroll are the very
same people promoting the regeneron
monoclonal antibody treatment which is
dramatically more profitable
than the vaccines just just remember
that to pedal in their lives
and so to that end today i'm going to
point out another truth and it will
likely be deemed a conspiracy theory
until it's not
there are too many healthy individuals
like bob saget who we know have received
their vaccinations who are dropping dead
suddenly and unexpectedly with no
further explanation now you have to
remember a number of different things
no further explanation
no immediate known cause of death could
it have been stroke heart attack etc at
some point if the information is
released by the family we will know but
understand that there's a fundamental
mathematical problem here
the closer you get to full vaccination
in a country the more likely it is that
everybody who dies will have been
vaccinated in a 100 vaccinated country
everybody who dies of a heart attack
will have been vaccinated whoa did the
vaccines cause heart attacks because
everybody who's dying from a heart
attack was vaccinated
everybody who dies from stroke will have
been vaccinated
wow you're telling me every stroke death
was in vaccinated people
in the united states now we are in the
low 60s vaccination that means anybody
who dies from anything there is a
two-thirds chance that they were
vaccinated causation correlation
candace owens doesn't care and this is
very irresponsible healthy athletes
young students in their physical prime
the majority of them males dropping
suddenly and unexpectedly in the middle
of games from heart issues
what we know for a fact is that these
people are being mandated to take the
vaccine and we know for a fact that
these vaccines come with a warning that
they bring about myocarditis now
remember the risk of myocarditis from
covet is higher but they now have this
is really a situation of when all you
have is a hammer
everything looks like a nail
i remember when i was a kid
the celtics player reggie lewis died
and
uh he was i'm let's see he was born in
65 died in 93 so he was 28 years old
um and there were no covet vaccines at
the time
that is a death where if it happened
today people like candace owens would be
saying it's got to be related to that
vaccine
and the truth is this happens and this
happens sadly more frequently than
people want want to believe i mentioned
on the bonus show on monday
that my my my cousin my second cousin my
mom's cousin fabian bielinski pretty
well-known argentinian film director
he died at age 47
was
healthy as far as we would normally say
a little bit overweight
um when he from a heart attack when he
was in brazil and you can look that up
on wikipedia
and uh it was it was tragic and
devastating and sad but these things do
happen and again when all you have is a
hammer which is wanting to criticize
vaccination
every death starts to look like a nail
that you can hammer in
there were no covet vaccines for a long
time and these things happen sadly all
the time there's almost eight billion
people on the planet as more and more
people get vaccinated more and more of
the people to whom everything happens
will be vaccinated uh traffic accidents
mostly will take the lives of vaccinated
people etc etc what candace owens is
doing is extraordinarily dangerous
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p here's a really
fair question about covet
hospitalizations and something i said
earlier this week let's take a listen to
it i welcome these types of uh
confrontations with the things that i
say because they're fair let's listen
hey david i had a question you were just
talking about um how hospit the
hospitalization data you were saying
that even though the hospitalizations
look high they're saying that not all of
the hospitalizations are because of
covid like a broken leg and they just
happen to also have code or something
and that makes sense but i remember in
the beginning of the pandemic um there
were you know a bunch of right wingers
making the same argument they're like oh
the hospitalizations are overrated you
know they're they're pretending like
it's covered when the person really died
of this and we were kind of discounting
that as just kind of
you know their their same old
shenanigans of just deflecting you know
finding any excuse to like downplay the
severity so why is it now
something that we're saying
like is there something specific about
the data that's just showing it so now
that's really the case yes that's
exactly it this is a great question
which is for a long time republicans
have been saying they haven't so much
been saying the hospitalization numbers
are exaggerated republicans have been
saying the death numbers are being
exaggerated and at one point they were
saying hospitals lie and say someone
died from kovid to get more money now we
debunked that what is true is that if
someone is in the hospital for covid on
average it's more expensive to treat
them than when someone does not have
covet so it doesn't matter if they die
or not medicare reimburses more money if
someone actually is treated for covid
because on average that's more expensive
to treat the difference is before there
was no data that pointed to a ton of the
people in the hospital with covid
being in the hospital for something else
before
you had a situation where
almost anything that was elective or
non-emergency was shut down
um
the hospitalization rate for the earlier
strains was higher
and there was no data that suggested
many of the people hospitalized right
now with covet are actually here for
something else we now have actual data
including for example from new york city
omicron is so contagious it is so
widespread and it is also asymptomatic
in so many people that in new york city
half of those in the hospital with kovid
were not in the hospital because of
covet they are not being treated with
covid they incidentally are positive but
they're there for something else so the
reason why we now can say that and
before we couldn't is that the data
actually reflects that it's a perfectly
fair question
and that's the answer
uh and they're exactly the types of
questions that we should be asking we
have a great bonus show for you today
we'll talk about novak djokovic facing
prison for breaking isolation while
coveted positive this guy is just
disgusting
we'll talk about bernie sanders uh plan
for everybody to get n95 masks not
crappy masks and we will talk about
infowars and alex jones claims about
being barely able to pay the bills
after they brought in 165 million
dollars in three years
get access to today's bonus show by
signing up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code wow 22 wow 22 to get a discount
we'll see you on the bonus check
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
magic spoon tastes exactly like your
favorite childhood breakfast cereals but
it has no sugar lots of protein it's
keto and low carb friendly it's
delicious without the guilt get five
dollars off when you click my link below
and use the promo code pacman